Hey Mahmud,
can you help me read this Arabic message
I got and I can't recognize any of the
words.
Oh,
that's not Arabic.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange focus channel.
My name is Paul.
In a recent video I talked about the
Persian language which is spoken in
Iran,
Afghanistan and Tajikistan because Iran
is located in the Middle East next to
Iraq.
A lot of people wonder if the Persian
language and Arabic are related.
Well they are not directly related but
they have influenced each other.
Persian and Arabic belonged to
completely different language families,
which means that they have separate
origins.
Arabic is a Semitic language and it
comes from the same root language as
Hebrew,
Aramaic,
phoenician,
go riddick,
et cetera.
Persian on the other hand is an Indo
European language,
the shares common roots with the
languages of northern India as well as
most of the languages in Europe such as
English,
French and German.
Therefore,
Persian and Arabic have very different
grammar and the way that words are
constructed is completely different.
Semitic languages have a unique system
of mostly three letter roots,
and these three that are roots are put
into templates that form the shape of
different words.
For example,
the Arabic root for learn,
which in English is like drs.
If you want to say,
I learn,
you take those three root letters and
you add them into this template here and
say odd reus Persian does not have this
system of putting the root into
templates.
The root words stay in one piece and
affixes are attached to it.
So let's look at an example in Persian
using the root word done,
which means no,
the first word is [inaudible],
which means to know.
So if we add the ethics Istan,
that creates the infinitive of the verb.
The next word is dawn Nash,
which means knowledge.
So the ethics ash creates an abstract
now than if we take that word and we add
another ethics at the end.
Donesh Monday,
that means scientist.
So that creates a concrete now.
So you can see that nothing is changing
with the route where.